elle était
maxime amis 0,72 secondes pour réagir au
coup de sifflet effrénée sur route sèche
sa distance de freinage et de 37 mètres
sur route mouillée 58 m même si j'étais
préparé à freiner au moment où il y
aurait eu l'oeil allait avoir le bruit
et ben même là j'avais quand même un
temps de réaction n'était pas loin d'une
seconde donc c'est vrai que c'est ce que
disaient les gens qui nous accompagnait
la base c'est que c'était que même en
conditions réelles ce serait pire en
terme de temps dans la réaction quoi
simulateur de conduite casque de réalité
virtuelle
ce bus toutes équipées et là pour
sensibiliser les étudiants de l'école de
commerce hec à la sécurité routière
une démarche menée par une entreprise de
location de véhicules d'entreprises dans
toute la france le bus dans lequel nous
trouver qui a comporte donc cette cet
atelier va aller dans cette ville de
france donc le tour de france a déjà
démarré par les villes de rennes se
poursuit à paris puis ensuite ce bus ira
sur lyon annecy par exemple sur l'alcool
au volant ils ont pas du tout là
l'impression de
de boire et de ne plus être maîtres de
leur véhicule le test qu'on leur fait
faire leur montre que à deux verres
d'alcool et les réactions et les temps
de réponse on sont amoindris par
l'alcool au volant serait responsable de
30% des accidents de la route en france
pour rappel la limite autorisée par la
loi et de 0 5 gramme d'alcool par litre
de sang
chaque année ce sont plus de 3000
personnes qui perdent la vie sur les
routes du territoire
[Musique]